cette fromagère tient bien un commerce
dit essentiel mais en confinement les
clients sont rares alors elle les trouve
sur internet
c'est une commande d'une cliente qui me
demandent du bleu des causses et
dubarbier la cliente passent commande
depuis chez elle au même moment en
boutique
sylvie la prépare ça nous aide à garder
contact avec nos clients et
travailler
quand même malgré le problème de
enfin un message positif sur la
devanture faire mes courses point fr un
site qui regroupe des milliers de
commerçants à travers la france
à issoudun ils sont une cinquantaine à
répondre présent depuis quelques jours
le principe faire ses courses 100 %
local en ligne sur une seule plateforme
une aubaine pour le maire de la commune
notre ambition c'est que ce site soit la
place du marché permanente de notre cité
et nous voulons l'élargir
parce que nous ne souhaitons par
seulement qu'il y ait des commerces nous
voulons aussi que les artisans puissent
y être présent et que tous donnent à
voir la richesse et la diversité des
activités de notre bassin de vie ici le
rideau est baissé commerce non
essentiels alors mélanie n'a pas hésité
à participer à l' aventure ben ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir on sent pas
oublié donc c'est un petit plus dans la
région d'autres villes sont présentes
c'est le cas entre autres de
joué-lès-tours châteaudun ou encore
saint-amand bon